Every now and again,
there's a movie that will sadly break an actor. Whether it's a run-in with an
unfortunate altercation are being unprepared for the truth, to being on the receiving end of the downright
twisted, there are moments that leave actors scarred and remind us that they are people too with their own fears and problems. Thankfully these onset
altercations did not affect the
determination of the actors who pulled through and carried on to finish their film. Here are 10
life-threatening movie moments that actors regret. Before we get started, can you name this movie from these emojis? If you enjoyed this video, don't forget
to give us a like, leave a comment, and subscribe to stay up to date on all things screen rant.
Alien. What is the scariest and most well-known moment from the original Alien film?
You're probably thinking of the chest burster scene, in which a baby alien
explodes from John Hurt's stomach. While it's fun knowing now that the cast was unprepared for the alien to pop out,
what may shock you more is learning that the baby xenomorph was partially made up of real human skulls.
Scriptwriter Dan O'Bannon revealed during the commentary for return of the living dead that artist H.R.
Giger went to India and bought human skulls for the prop. Even more unsettling is that the
Xenomorph's teeth are made up from the skulls of
human children El Banat observed.
Yikes,I bet he wish he didn't know that.
Thank you, Mr. Bates.
Norman Bates.
Psycho. Another iconic moment in horror comes from the classic film "Psycho." As we're all aware in that film, Janet Leigh's character is
ultimately brutally murdered halfway through the movie in the iconic shower scene. However, the scene did quite a number on the actress. Leigh has stated that
filming the scene left her so rattled that she decided to never do shower scenes, providing
it was absolutely necessary to the plot. The actress would later state that watching the scene over again left her realizing
how vulnerable and defenseless one is.
The Last House on the Left
Sometimes being too real might be crossing a line when it comes to the safety of the actors. Wes Craven's breakout film, the original "Last
House on the Left," is a prime example
of this. One of the many horrible moments the cast had to endure on set saw actor David Hess is
confronted with a chainsaw. The twist here is that it isn't a prop.
It's a fully operational chainsaw with no safety precautions in place to keep Hess safe.
Couple this with Mark Schaefer holding Sandra Castle over a drop to get a reaction, and actual fist fighting for a shot,
and it's no wonder these actors didn't quit acting all together.
Halloween. One of the pillars of the slasher horror
genre, [Halloween] is deemed a terrifying classic and at the time of release, in the 70s, was pure terror.
Especially for child actor Kyle Richards, age 9, who played Lindsay Wallace in the John Carpenter film. Yet
it wasn't until Richards saw the final
product at the premiere that she felt the true terror of the film, which resulted in the young actress having to sleep with her mom
until the age of 15 due to fear of someone sinister hiding under her bed. Talk about child therapy.
This is why we avoid bringing children to r-rated horror movie premieres. Here's Johnny!
The Shining.
Here's Stanley! Stanley Kubrick was known for being something of an intense director, often doing his takes fifty to a hundred
times and pushing his actors to their breaking point in order to get the best possible shot for his film.
This was no different when it came to The Shining, as Kubrick pulled no punches
with actress Shelley duvall who played Wendy. The actress was repeatedly pushed to the limit by Kubrick to the point of bullying which resulted in
Duval collapsing on set and her hair to actually fall out due to stress during the year-long shoot
Ironically about going mad. Don't know about you, but hair loss due to stress on the job doesn't sound like the best cup of tea
Die Hard
yippee-Ki-yay
am I right, mother flippers? The first die hard would go on to become one of the most beloved action films of all time and
introduced the world to the extremely talented Alan Rickman who made his theatrical debut as the German terrorist Hans Gruber to Bruce Willis's
NYPD officer, John McClane. In the Film's Climax,
Rickman is being suspended from the side of the High-rise and learn notified he would drop on the count of three what he didn't know
Is that director John McTiernan had a trick up his sleeve and dropped the actor on the count of one what you see is Alan
Rickman's genuine reaction as he plummets the actor was reportedly furious with McTiernan and would good cause as when doing a stunt like that
It's best to be mentally prepared to prevent any
injuries thankfully this didn't happen and hans would go on to become one of the most iconic villains ever
Aguirre, Wrath of God. You may not have heard of Aguirre, Wrath of God, the 1972 West German Epic, but
You'll have a hard time forgetting it after this story during the production
Director werner Herzog threatened lead actor Klaus Kinski to make sure he didn't leave the movie the catch is that he threatened the actor at
gunpoint
even firing said gun into a cabin filled with people because he found they were too loud which resulted in someone losing the tip of
their finger the director admitted in
1999 that he tried to have Kinski murdered by burning him alive
Which was prevented due to Kinski's dog. The director remained Adamant at the two were friends
but that the professional relationship ordered on
Psychotic and that he genuinely wanted to kill the actor note to self don't work on any films with any potentially psychotic directors
The Omen. When you make a film dealing with the son of the
Antichrist, you're bound to get a few bizarre mishaps during the production and perhaps a few tragic occurrences.
That's exactly what happened during the shoot for the original omen. The film saw its fair share of actual death around the cast and crew
starting with the tragic suicide of
Gregory Peck's son just two months before the premiere
Peck was almost killed himself when he missed a flight which in turn ended up crashing. Mere weeks after that, the animal handler was eaten
Alive by a lion maybe this film is indeed cursed if that wasn't weird enough though a special effects supervisor John Richardson's assistant
Lismore was gruesomely decapitated in a car accident after he himself designed a decapitation scene in the film featuring David warner
Thedate of the accident, friday the 13th
1976 all this is only the original version too. Please, no one remake the omen again
The Birds. Hitchcock strikes again on our list. In
1963 the Master of Horror released the Birds which would also become a classic in the genre in it actress tippi Hedren ends up being
Constantly haunted and tormented by the infamous birds themselves. Only there was something not quite right with these birds
Initially she was led to believe from Hitchcock himself that there were to be
Mechanical creatures and would be under the control of the film crew much to her own horror she discovered that the birds were in fact
Real with no control over the animal's behavior any actor might worry about one safety when it comes to potential injuries
Especially ones eyes, talk about being terrified by real-life birds for the rest of your life
Noah. when she's not casting spells or capturing hearts
Emma Watson is certainly creating a lasting impression with fans. The former Harry Potter alum
And un Goodwill ambassador has done a lot of good out there
But that doesn't mean the beloved actress has it easy while I'm set for Darren Aronofsky's Noah, Watson
Had an uncomfortable brush in with a stalker who confronted the actress in the woods during a biblical shoot in 2012
According to Daily mail Watson recognized the man from previous run-ins only this time he had confronted her alone in the woods
Thankfully security and the stun team caught up with the man who attempted to run away and was warned that she was trespassing
While one of our favorite witches must have regretted wandering off to the woods alone. She nonetheless overcame such a shocking moment
That's it for today everyone. What did you think of our list you feel bad for these actors? Are you happy?
They pull through their ordeals whether they are planned or a product of their environment?
Whatever you think let us know in the comments and hit that subscribe button, but wait
there's more hop on over to CBr for even more awesome content and sign up for the
Notification squad to stay up to date on all the awesome videos coming your way